jumpin water droplets have sprung to new  heights thanks to a strange phenomenon  called trampoline II when a water  droplet trampolines  it not only bounces on a completely  rigid surface it gains height with each  leap like a gymnast does on a trampoline  without warning the droplet  spontaneously starts to bounce but  where's the jump start the droplet is  kept in a low pressure environment and  rests on a surface that repels water and  is bumpy on the micro level these bumps  keep the water droplet from making full  contact with the surface key for its  levitation and bounce ability as the  water naturally begins to vaporize  pressure builds below the drop and  essentially launches the water droplet  off the surface because vaporization  also cools water the drop can freeze  making this setup appealing for things  like the icing imagine ice removing  itself one frozen droplet at a time  you